alors aymeric aymeric vous connaissez
pas forcément vous prenez sur vous
l'avez vu donc dans quoi dans ces quatre
story sur la dernière saison c'est vrai
qu'ils vivent et j'ai une pensée pour ta
femme parce que je la connais bien le
niveau
non mais c'est elle qui m'a lancé sur
secret story tf1 ne voulait pas de moi
voilà trois ans et pendant trois ans il
voulait pas de moyens de tenir le 5 mai
2004 ce remake sharm al khaimah saison
par benjamin déjà à ça n'existe plus
beau et bon on me dit ça n'est rien du
tout mais bon choix
attend il a même repris ma boudouil mais
elles méritent ils voulaient pas toi et
elle a pleuré le jour et moi aussi que
je reçois quand même nom mais cela fait
du mal tout est histoire de cambrai mais
c'est vrai c'est vrai et franchement je
suis fait un gros bisou c'était son
anniversaire cette semaine donc je
t'embrasse très fort mort mais rose
pailleté beaucoup pleurent c'est pas
nous c'est pas gros mais pas et était
beaucoup plus tôt qu'avant
ouais parce que je faisais du rugby à un
niveau assez importants dont je faisais
beaucoup de musculation mais comme mais
comme motown
faut pas déconner non plus ouais j'ai
été obligé de maigrir parce que tf1 ne
souhaitait pas avoir quelqu'un de trop
costaud à l'antenne voilà qu'à l'avant
voilà bah bah ça c'était pas dans les
codes escargots
mais attention c'était pas ça c'était
pas épais du sens voilà c'était pas de
je ne sais pas si c'est le fait gaffe
avec laurent ournac paraître
[Applaudissements]
les types athlétique
ouais ah oui bon ça donc ça j'avais 17
ans là dessus un golgoth sur la personne
visée
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]